Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Design.
Tutti apprezziamo il grande design.
Ci sono design estremamente iconici,
come la Valentine;
ci sono sedie,
che più o meno ogni designer
pensa di progettare in un momento
della loro vita, apparentemente;
poi c'è design che viene dalla stampa,
quindi design ibrido, design misto.
E quindi ci sono - un esempio recente,
di fusione tra software e hardware.
Ma la domanda qui è: ok,
questi sono esempi di grande design.
Ma perché ci manca l'abilità
di fare un buon design,
non eccellenza per forza,
ma continuamente?
Be', vorrei partire dal presupposto
che il design è, di base,
transdisciplinare.
È un design che coinvolge
e include discipline multiple,
quindi sicuramente la parte visuale
ma anche la psicologia
- comprendere come verrà utilizzato;
ma anche la tecnologia,
anche il business
- perché bisogna capire come questo
viene poi portato agli utenti.
Ma questo ci porta poi
a uno dei problemi
di cui voglio parlare oggi:
ok, ci sono grandi skill
che si possono avere;
ma poi ci si scontra con l'ego.
L'ego si scontra col designer
per un motivo abbastanza semplice,
ci immergiamo nel lavoro che facciamo,
proiettiamo tanto
di noi stessi, nel lavoro.
E quindi quello che va a succedere
è che ci identifichiamo col progetto,
con l'idea, con il concept,
con quello che è stato realizzato.
E questo porta, ovviamente,
a una commistione dell'io della persona
con il lavoro che viene fatto.
E se noi prendiamo
il termine ego, o ego,
e ovviamente ci sono tante
definizioni psicologiche molto specifiche
ma ci sono anche definizioni più comuni,
che è quella che di solito
viene utilizzata,
e di solito viene utilizzata
con accezione negativa.
Quindi il senso di importanza
di noi stessi, la nostra autostima.
Che appunto, è positivo avere,
ma nella connotazione negativa
causa molti problemi.
E proprio perché l'ego
è questa cosa che ci chiude
dentro a noi stessi,
l'ego è anche il più grande
nemico del design,
che invece per sua natura
è transdisciplinare,
interconnette le persone;
ed è la necessità del buon design.
E quindi l'impatto sulla persona è grave,
perché neghiamo
quello che sta succedendo.
Una persona con un grosso ego
non è in grado di accettare le critiche
e si chiude, si difende.
Talvolta anche sfocia in rabbia.
C'è una disconnessione emotiva
che quindi non aiuta a capire gli altri.
E ovviamente andiamo a perdere
la capacità di crescita della persona,
che non accetta più consigli,
non accetta suggerimenti.
Poi abbiamo però anche
un impatto sul design stesso,
perché questa incapacità diminuisce
la creatività del risultato,
la creatività della soluzione.
La qualità diminuisce.
Non c'è possibilità di sperimentare.
E ovviamente, la mancanza di diversità
porta a una carenza del design finale.
Ed infine c'è un altro aspetto,
che è quello del team.
E questo è molto, molto interessante
perché è spesso sottovalutato.
Ma l'impatto sul team è enorme,
ed è evidente nel lungo termine,
soprattutto:
perché continua a degradare, le persone
non si sentono responsabilizzate.
Se quella persona
prende tutte le decisioni,
cosa ci sono qui io a fare?
La collaborazione viene distrutta:
non viene dato potere alle persone
e ai talenti individuali.
E ovviamente abbassa il morale del team,
e questo danneggia il gruppo,
la società, nel lungo termine.
E quindi dobbiamo affrontare l'ego.
Per affrontarlo, ci sono vari modi
ma partirei da una delle citazioni
di Bruno Murari, grande designer italiano
che in una delle sue lezioni disse:
ok, siamo persone, quindi
ognuno di noi avrà un suo stile,
il suo - cioè quello che gli piace fare,
un suo talento specifico;
ma quando mi proietto nel design,
quando faccio design
quello viene messo da parte
e creo qualcosa di diverso
per il prodotto,
per quello che sto facendo.
A livello personale,
per risolvere questo problema
la prima cosa da fare
è separare l'idea dell'ego,
questa nostra difesa,
da quello che noi siamo.
Capire che non siamo noi.
Se vogliamo, dobbiamo cominciare a capire
questa voce interna che dice: io.
Se iniziamo ad accorgerci che esiste,
iniziamo ad accorgerci che non
siamo noi, quello è il primo passo.
E vale per noi, soprattutto.
E questo viene da ricerche
nell'ambito della mindfulness,
della meditazione, delle neuroscienze.
E uno dei modelli che è stato creato
ci dice che noi cerchiamo il focus,
cerchiamo quel momento,
quella concentrazione,
quell'abilità di trovare il centro
nel lavoro che facciamo,
nel design che facciamo.
Ma è impossibile tenerlo a lungo.
E quindi il focus pian piano degrada,
e va a inserirsi in questo loop,
in questo circolo vizioso di pensieri
che si connettono l'uno dopo l'altro,
e continuano nella nostra testa
a connettersi uno di fianco all'altro.
E l'ego è uno di questi circoli viziosi.
E la cosa interessante è che un sacco
degli approcci si focalizzano su:
"come mantengo il focus,
come riesco a mantenere,
a creare condizioni ideali per il focus".
Ma dalle ricerche fatte,
soprattutto nell'ambito
della mindfulness,
andiamo a scoprire che [sì,]
quello è sicuramente uno degli aspetti;
ma è altrettanto importante allenare
l'abilità di accorgersi
quando siamo in quel circolo vizioso,
e quindi saltare fuori.
E questa abilità può essere allenata.
Chiaramente, la prima volta
che lo facciamo
riusciremo a mantenere il focus
per l'1% di tempo
e pian piano questo si ampierà.
È un talento, un'abilità
che possiamo sviluppare.
E questo riesce a rompere per noi
al di fuori del circolo vizioso
che è l'ego, questo sistema difensivo.
Oppure la cosa più semplice
che possiamo fare:
se ci accorgiamo che sta per succedere,
andiamo a fare una camminata.
Le ricerche ci hanno detto
che il miglior modo di farlo
è fare una camminata nel verde.
A livello del design,
di modi per affrontare l'ego
ce ne sono vari
e in modo assolutamente interessante,
molti dei processi di design,
seppur senza dirlo,
cercano di minimizzare
il ruolo dell'ego
all'interno del processo,
all'interno della produzione del design.
Uno dei trucchi, ad esempio, Pixar.
Ed Catmull ci racconta
che tutte le persone coinvolte
nella realizzazione di un film
si trovano ogni mattina
condividendo qualunque tipo di lavoro
sia stato fatto il giorno precedente.
Può essere incompleto,
può essere parziale:
non importa, tutti discutono di tutto.
E questo permette
di far diventare il lavoro
dal lavoro dell'individuo
al lavoro dei tanti.
Permette di allenarsi
ad affrontare il nostro ego,
e a capire che giorno
dopo giorno dopo giorno,
lavoro dopo lavoro dopo lavoro,
questo può essere affrontato.
Un altro aspetto estremamente importante
è quello di criticare il design,
ma non la persona.
È molto facile dire:
"Ah, quel lavoro che hai fatto
è estremamente brutto,
o dobbiamo sistemare questo problema
che hai nel tuo design".
Quando invece è molto più semplice dire:
"Risolviamo assieme
il problema del design,
risolviamo assieme il problema
di questa proposta che abbiamo davanti".
Quindi la separazione aiuta
perché ci permette di dire al team
che "hai fatto un buon lavoro,
e assieme andiamo a risolvere
i problemi rimanenti".
Assieme andiamo a migliorare
quello che è stato fatto.
E quindi è un modo per evitare l'ego.
A livello del team
è molto difficile però capire
quando c'è l'ego considerato
come abilità di essere confidenti,
sicuri di se stessi;
e invece l'arroganza.
La differenza è
che quando uno va a presentare
davanti a un team, a un gruppo
di vice president, per esempio,
una cosa è entrare nella stanza e dire
- presentare il design con sicurezza,
con la ricerca che è stata fatta,
con le idee che sono uscite,
e accettare consigli e vedere
come si può migliorare, assieme.
E un'altra invece
è entrare nella stessa stanza,
ma invece essere sicuri
che quello è il design migliore
che possa essere mai fatto.
Talvolta questi due [approcci],
da fuori, è facile confonderli,
soprattutto in un primo momento.
E per distinguerli basta vedere
come e quanto la persona
è in grado di ascoltare.
La capacità di ascoltare
è assolutamente fondamentale,
non soltanto perché il design,
come è spesso detto,
è user-centric, è centrato sull'utente;
ma anche perché
è importante portare assieme
tutti i consigli che possono
arrivare, ovunque.
Questo ci permette sia di lavorare
sulla capacità di ascoltare,
ma anche per riconoscere
quale delle due tipologie di ego
ci troviamo davanti.
E poi la cosa fondamentale:
la capacità di dare merito,
di dire [che] queste persone
hanno aiutato nel progetto.
Mi è capitato veramente troppo spesso
che addirittura a livello di contratto
l'azienda vietasse di parlare del fatto
che io avessi lavorato ad un progetto.
Questo è assolutamente distruttivo.
E uno potrebbe dire:
ma perché dare credito?
Dare credito non stimola l'ego?
Be', se è fatto male, sì.
Ma se noi pensiamo a una cosa,
l'ego è anche lì perché
vogliamo essere riconosciuti.
E se ci troviamo in un team,
in un gruppo di persone, di lavoro
dove sappiamo che se abbiamo fatto
un buon lavoro ci verrà riconosciuto,
l'ego non ha ragione di attivarsi.
E dare credito può essere fatto
sia nel piccolo,
con un ringraziamento,
ovviamente compensato
al tipo di lavoro che è stato fatto.
Ma se ci spostiamo dai consigli
che possiamo applicare ogni giorno
sul nostro mondo di lavoro
e nel nostro piccolo,
c'è una domanda che continua
a tornare nella mia testa:
ma perché continuiamo a premiarlo?
Perché continuiamo a celebrare individui,
manager, grandi designer
che invece dimostrano
tutti i tratti dell'ego negativo?
Ci sono effettivamente biases, deviazioni.
Il bias è quando noi percepiamo
il mondo in un certo modo
e lo vediamo così in modo naturale:
è naturale pensare in un certo modo,
anche se è un'interpretazione
del mondo negativa.
E ad esempio uno dei bias
è quello della sopravvivenza,
cioè il fatto che noi analizziamo
solo le persone che hanno avuto successo,
e non le migliaia che non l'hanno avuto.
Analizziamo il design che ha
avuto successo, e chi l'ha fatto,
e non tutti quelli che hanno fallito.
E quando andiamo a osservare
questo più da vicino,
ci accorgiamo che molto spesso
un design, una soluzione, un'azienda
non ha avuto successo
grazie a questo ego:
ha avuto successo nonostante l'ego.
Un altro bias molto grosso
è quello che io definisco
con un termine inglese, smart ass.
Che non riesco a tradurre
molto bene in italiano,
però significa che - sono state fatte
delle ricerche, negli anni '80 -
e quando venivano proposti due feedback,
due consigli assolutamente identici,
di cui uno negativo
e uno posto in modo gentile,
quello negativo veniva percepito
come più intelligente.
Ma se noi percepiamo
il mondo in questo modo
dobbiamo accorgerci che forse
dobbiamo fare una correzione.
È assolutamente preferibile lavorare
con la persona più gentile,
che è in grado di proporsi
in modo non confrontativo.
Quindi come possiamo superare questo?
Be', i bias si affrontano accorgendosene.
E l'ultimo bias è quello
che chiamo del genio solitario.
Questa idea, celebrata
incredibilmente dai media,
che dice che è una persona che ha creato,
è una persona che ha realizzato
questo grande design,
una persona che ha portato
avanti questa società.
Questi tre bias si uniscono assieme,
e ci portano a celebrare queste persone
che in realtà hanno lavorato
assieme, in gruppi.
E ad esempio, se noi
pensiamo a Steve Jobs
che viene celebrato
per le sue abilità di design,
per le sue abilità organizzative,
per il suo genio,
per le sue abilità [nel] business -
ma forse la sua abilità primaria
è stata quella,
lungo tutta la sua storia,
di essersi sempre affiancato
con i migliori talenti che trovava.
E non c'è bisogno
di andare tanto distante:
anche in Italia Adriano Olivetti,
grandissimo imprenditore,
ha fatto grandissime cose in Italia;
una visione eccezionale.
Ma anche lì, [se] andiamo a vedere,
si circondava di grandissimi designer.
Per esempio Gae ha creato
i concept store, i negozi di Olivetti
che si dice siano stati
d'ispirazione per quelli di Apple.
E alcuni se ne accorgono:
se noi prendiamo Lady Gaga,
il suo team creativo ha un brand.
Le persone che lavorano con lei
sono celebrate con un brand,
con un'identificazione particolare
che è Haus of Gaga.
E quindi lei capisce
che è difficile per il mondo accorgersi
di tutte queste persone che lavorano,
e che sono assolutamente
fondamentali per il suo successo
- e ha creato un brand
per aiutarle a venire riconosciute.
In definitiva, il messaggio è:
affrontiamo l'ego.
Affrontiamolo in noi,
aiutiamo gli altri ad affrontarlo,
affrontiamolo nel mondo del lavoro
perché il design,
in fondo, è molto umile.
E il design di successo
è umile per definizione.
Grazie.
(Applausi)